5 14 on your friday morning so even if
the fourth or fifth grader in your life
isn't exactly thinking about college
right now the welcome that students at
wendell williams elementary got when
they arrived on campus the other day
likely to stick with them
[Applause]
just one of the 22 students from howard
university part of a 20 year old
alternative spring break program it just
made me feel warm to see that we're able
to at least give them like a jump start
in the day and just say you know good
morning my name is shayla hughes i'm a
freshman criminology major they dropped
in on classes
asking a future nba star his favorite
current team principal cynthia ireland
says the college kid visit isn't just
talk what they're going to do is meet
with our fourth and fifth graders today
to set up pathway to success goals
they'll have an accountability partner
not only at school but also at home
we'll set action steps to make sure that
they are successful she put the school's
goals
in a nutshell if our boys and girls know
that we care about them and know how
much we love them and support them to be
successful they will believe in
themselves and they will soar mr wendell
p williams our namesake pours into our
students who looks like our students i
think that means the world for them to
see students from howard university and
i think it makes their dream come true
even more
well jania took advantage of howard's
alternative spring break all four years
they're giving younger students a vision
of what their own futures might be she's
graduating in just a couple of months
now if you know something that's cool at
school let us know cool at school under
the community tab at eightnewsnow.com or
you can just send us an email
coolantschool
eightnewsnow.com that is super cool that
is great it was really fun to see the
little you know the kindergartners and
the fourth and fifth graders going who
are all these people
they got this giant parade of high fives
and they're dancing around it was great
but you got a flavor they get a flavor
of what it's like at a younger age of
you know down the line yeah so in
the classrooms of the fourth and fifth
graders are going you guys have you
thought about where you're going to be
when you grow up and then obviously
football star basketball star whatever
but you know it gets them thinking it
sure does